this is this is something i was talking
about i had a really long conversation
with my friend the other day it was
really interesting
and i said i think what we're seeing is
the left word lurch
is an is is uh it's got too much
momentum
yeah effectively what happened is it's
something i described before we have
tribalism
which means that the the uh political
factions are divided to a point where
it's nonsensical
now for the most part i think whatever
side we're on i'm i'm a pretty liberal
individual like
like old school liberal whatever the
left is something entirely tribalistic
and nonsensical
so i'm sure you and i disagree a lot of
things yeah but we get along just fine
talking politics even if we disagree
right so that's so i don't want to claim
that the tribalism
is equally bad i don't think it is but
the left is now
you know adhering to uh there
i kind of lost my train of thought
because i started getting into the
the whole right right what were you
talking about before this
conspiracy theories so one's on the left
no i think i lost my train of thought i
had a really good point it just slipped
out of me
you know there it's gone that's it it's
over sorry everybody it was going to be
the most profound epiphany ever it was
going to change the world and save
everyone and that was it
and i got to be honest with you not a
good time to lose that
yeah epiphany pre-epiphany i think you
made a really good point when you talked
about the fact that people on the left
can push
conspiracy theories and other really bad
ideas with impunity
um and i think i think it's true when
it's accurate and it's fair to say that
we have a crisis in this country of call
it fake news call it whatever you want
but of disinformation
of people believing facts that just
aren't so and an inability for our
current systems to keep up
with those facts that aren't true i
remember the epiphany oh
good yeah it was the left word lurch
that's what i was talking about and so
what i was saying is
because the left isn't talking about
policy
so much as whatever you say we disagree
with it's turned into this weird thing
where
the media and our cultural institutions
always side with the left yep
there was a study a few years ago i
covered where they mapped out twitter
and they found that brand marketing
existed
overlapping with the resistance the
anti-trump resistance on twitter
yeah probably because the same people
who work in marketing
live in the same areas and are friends
with the same people who work in
journalism
so when they see their friends tweet
something like orange man bad they think
i know let's put an ad campaign for our
soda company called orange man bed or
the soda company goes to them and say
what sells
orange man bad right that's why you end
up with rainbow logos for every single
company and i think what february is
yeah
not february april that sounds right i'm
sorry i remember which month i don't
mean that to be disrespectful but that's
i just don't remember
maybe it's june actually that uh all the
rainbow logos appear
because all the brands agree on the same
thing right if you come out and say
something negative
you'll be banned right so that's the
left word lurch the momentum is too
strong so covid is a really good example
if you come out and say there's a really
interesting study on kovac
band yup but if you come out and say the
it's the end of the world covet is
killing everybody
and we have to lock down forever you're
good or how about this
donald trump is personally responsible
for 80 to 90 of deaths
so joe biden said that yeah and the
washington post actually said he made
that up it's completely wrong
you know and and i respect them for
calling him out for me too that's yeah
good on them but is that video going to
get taken down
are they going to become no no joe biden
says of course not that's not going to
get taken down there's not going to be
consequences there's not going to be any
cancel culture
so lost youtube privileges let's put it
this way you have two people standing
before the world
one guy on the left one guy on the right
the guy on the left yells at top of his
lungs
kovit is going to kill everybody
everyone shut down your businesses and
hide in your homes
and they go ah the guy on the right says
everybody calm down it's not that bad
the mortality rate isn't that bad and
then he gets removed from the scene
now you only have one guy screeching the
end as an eye right
and so everyone just runs for it and
goes and hides and anytime any one of
these people pops up and says i disagree
gone yep so you had i think it was
the best example of this is breitbart
when they got their video removed from
facebook
breitbart filmed a press conference of
doctors
one of which was was was you know
considered to be a cookie doctor sure
whatever fine
but you had a press conference in dc
breitbart is a news organization
all they did was film it it was put on
by a congress member
facebook removed it because of what the
the the doctors said yeah
so so breitbart didn't say it
breitbart was just a news organization
saying a congressman held a press
conference
shouldn't they just put like a fact
check or something i mean
even that you think but even that goes
farther than i think they should
it's like it's a news organization who
filmed some doctors and a congressman
and here's what they said that's not why
is facebook removing
a news organization right it's because
the leftward lurch
you're allowed to say things in favor of
leftist orthodoxy even if
everyone disagrees with it so i'll tell
you the craziest thing that i was told
i had a friend tell me that they're you
know kind of a liberal
but that they are scared of how the left
is going in terms of abortion because
they think it's wrong
interesting okay and i said then you
need to go tell people that and they
said oh
god no like i can't i can't say anything
like that
and i said what if it's true that every
one of your friends agrees with you but
the only reason you think this is
because none of you will say it
what if you come out and say it well the
problem is the other people
you know like the other people in the on
the left even if they agree
will be like i'm not going to be the
deviant and they're going to point and
they're going to
you know his head exactly but you know
who can always be the deviant you can
always lean
left and i think that's the the key of
the lurch is that the only the only
person who's never going to be
problematically offensive
within that worldview is the person who
pushes it a little bit farther right
yeah a little bit more critical to the
critical race theory or the critical
gender theory or whatever it is
you can always go further to the left
without having to worry
that you're going to be the bad guy and
so it is it's this drift and you get all
of these
kind of like you get these people who
are dragged along with it who don't like
like your friend who don't like doing it
that's the cato study we talked about
it's the 60
of people who like there are probably
lots and lots of people who i know in dc
who work for liberal organizations
who just aren't quite liberal enough and
they're a little bit worried that like
that guy who lost his job for retweeting
a link that said that
destructive riots aren't politically
beneficial right that they hurt your
custody and the guy lost a job i mean
it's like
it's that crazy you know what they can
do though what in secret
they can vote they can vote i don't
think it's enough
um i think it's good i don't think it's
enough and i think one of the one of the
issues is
if you control culture you've won yeah
and so maybe not permanently but for now
you know
what is what is it saying whoever
controls the past controls the president
who controls the president
is that 1984 or something that sounds
like it should be it sounds orwellian
that's
right maybe it's animal farm so here's
what happens
people are seeing all this happen around
them and they're getting scared they go
into the voting booth and they vote for
trump
the leftists and media use this as proof
white supremacy america is a white
supremacist country see right the races
got elected again that proves it
young people who don't know better are
being indoctrinated into that new world
so they aren't voting they will grow up
and say this is what the media has told
me my whole life
this must be true right and then the
secret pro-trumpers
who wouldn't speak up and wouldn't teach
the next generation are gone
and you have a brave new world an
aurelian yeah i mean i i think you're
right and part of it too
is you know you've it's it's also like
who are the types of people who tend to
be teachers like
the political bent of a lot of very
important informative organizations
happening left
journalists teachers all these other
individuals and so
because of that you do have this this
kind of surround sound of a certain
perspective
that a bunch of young impressionable
people and even not young but generally
impressionable people
take as a given take as a fact take as a
reality that's going on around them
and they don't know any better and i
think it's particularly true if you
don't have people who are super into
politics
yeah i think the one the the one thing
that people are missing is the schools
and it's it's amazing to me that
conservatives are fighting so hard to
get their kids back into them
when we're seeing these leaked
curriculums showing that it's all like
gone in in a crazy indoctrination
they're telling the kids all of these
insane things yeah i mean there's a
weird dogma and there's some
i think twitter honestly is is probably
what opened my eyes to it but there's
some really good people who make a
really good push for
don't send your kids to government
schools you can homeschool if you can't
homeschool
send your kids to private schools if you
can't afford private schools find a
charter that'll take you in
like there are a lot of other options
and i think that's what you got to do
you know i i think you you've got to
start finding models to break it because
it's not going away on its own right you
look at something like the la unified
school district
there's no there's no amount of reform
or tweaks or change or god forbid money
that's going to fix that thing
right and so i wonder if you don't just
have to let it go on its own
or if nothing else you got to kind of
say hey it
sucks it's a shame but my kids aren't
going to have to suffer the consequences
of this thing school choice
yeah and you know uh trump included that
as a agenda for a second term
yeah and it's really amazing we had a
colin do you know colin wright
he's a 32 evolutionary biologist we had
him on uh
i think earlier this week and he talks a
lot about gender and stuff and he
mentioned how he used to be opposed to
it
you know because he thought it was going
to be used to teach evolution and
creationism
but now that he sees what the
intersectional the identitarian left is
doing he's like school choice voucher
program
get the kids put them where you want
because this has gone too far
and i'm right there with him the
craziest thing to me is
earlier this year and and i really do
love talking about guns now because i'm
like a new gun guy
ah okay i got it and so earlier this
year i was like i don't want any guns in
my house now i have six
amazing i shouldn't have said that also
i also have other other uh
legal means of defense outside of those
there too so just indeed
yeah but i do i do i do definitely we
have uh i mentioned this i think crowder
asked me
and i was just like oh we got a bunch of
compound bows a bunch of recurve bows
amazing yeah we're
like we're ever since the riots happened
yeah i don't blame you
i've i've gone we had we had um uh corey
d'angelos on
and then oh he explained great yeah he's
brilliant he explained to me voucher
program school choice and i was like
it's brilliant i love it yeah let's do
it why can't parents choose where their
kids go to school yeah
and then uh when the riots broke out and
uh i saw it was happening
and i heard the helicopters and when i
bought a bunch of guns so there has been
a big
rightward lurch too a sort of shock to
liberals
yeah who were asleep not paying
attention and i'm someone who did
pay attention but for the most part i
was like well i'm not gonna buy a gun
what am i eating and riot's happening
and i'm like i'm gonna go buy a gun
yeah i bought a bunch yeah i don't
believe and i think what you're gonna
see is you're gonna like as someone who
lives in dc and is familiar enough with
the dc gun laws to know that they're
pretty awful
i think you're also going to see a lot
of people leaving the cities for those
sorts of reasons too
right and i think i think you make a
really really good point on the school
choice stuff because i think that
people were fed up with their their
schools already but now the way that
they're handling the corona buyer stuff
i think is going to be what puts a lot
of people over the edge and they say you
know what this is too important
my children's education is too important
for me to screw up particularly in a
hyper competitive world
that i can't just let them walk down the
road to school even if that's the
closest easiest option even if their
friends are there whatever
because it's it's it's too great to
sacrifice it's not just that it's
have you heard about these pods that are
popping up i have yeah so so parents
their
their kids aren't in school so they're
teaming up and putting all the kids
under like they're all pitching in for a
tutor and the tutor teaches all the kids
right
saves money for everybody yeah instead
of having one tutor teach one kid you
have one two to teach 20 kids
congratulations you made a school
yep so now you've got parents who are
saying if i'm gonna be paying this tutor
by pitching in with all my friends why
are my taxes going to a school i don't
use
exactly i would like my money back yeah
and trump said we're going to get you
your money back yeah
it makes sense why would we you know and
you can't blame them right i mean
i think you know you're right and the
other thing too is it
it solves for the socialization problem
caused by the pandemic right
it obviously it helps the parents out
tremendously and they get a better
experience having a tutor than having
their parents teach them but it also
lets kids be kids and allow them to play
with their friends and go out and do all
the sorts of things that they can't do
right now in the pandemic
and i think they are going to sit back
and say hey you know this wasn't so bad
right i think if i think if the if this
continues to happen with schools you're
going to have a lot of people who go
through
half of a school year or a whole school
year and you have these
disaffected parents who are like i don't
know they're maybe like crunchy
granola-y like pretty leftward-leaning
people who were like
this isn't terrible and i think actually
it's a lot better than this now scary
alternative that i haven't seen before
i think the most important thing is that
uh kids spend too much time socializing
with each other
so i so i'll put it this way i look at
schools and what do we see
the teachers and the students are
typically adversarial the kids like
school sucks that's like kids say it all
the time yeah well they're going to a
place they hate
they're they're under the command or
authority of someone they don't like
they can't even go to the bathroom if
they need to unless they get permission
that's a horribly authoritarian system
and then they're getting their social
cues from other people who have no
understanding of social cues outside of
so it's like you take two people who
can't speak any languages and put them
in a room and they start making up weird
gibberish words
they're not going to function properly
in the greater society yeah so that's
why i say kids
are socializing too much what we need is
kids to be around their parents
that's why i'm i'm a big fan of
homeschooling but with these pods
so you have regular adults the kids can
be around and i also think it's very
important that parents spend a lot of
time teaching their own kids
yeah so i think you know if you go back
to where you know how humanity
essentially was developing at a certain
point i'm not going to speak i'm not an
anthropologist
but the kid would the dad would be a
blacksmith and the kid would grow up
and his dad would be showing him what he
did right but more importantly they
would be like yo go grab a bale of water
i need it for
you know whatever and the kid would go
do it and then the kids growing up being
told here's what you need here's why you
need it here's what i need go get it for
me
eventually that kid's a teenager and
he's also a blacksmith he's an
apprentice
so he he learns his whole life he's
around all the people coming and
you know you know patronizing the
business
and then he learns how to be a
functioning human in this world
today we've we've removed that right you
you have kids who grow up have no idea
how taxes work
don't even know they've got to pay them
yeah they're like what do you mean i
gotta file a form says who
when how yeah exactly they don't know
how to even get a job they don't know
what to do they don't make a resume you
go to school they don't know how to tell
you how banks work not none of that yeah
they don't know how to be an employee
either i mean
they don't know how to be an employer
also the craziest thing to me
is that when i was younger i i i just i
was just sitting there thinking one day
and i thought how do you make money
like how do you get money to buy
something you want and i realized all
i've got to do
is convince that guy holding that green
piece of paper to put the green piece of
paper in my hand
it's really fundamentally that simple so
what can you do to get it and it has to
be honest
you don't you can't defraud somebody and
you can't take it from my force
so i've got to find a way to convince
them that he should give me that so you
can do you can trade something
i can say i can give you this object i
can i made you a paper
boat give me a dollar or you can say i
will uh you know help you with your
homework
what can you do to convince them and
that's how you make money not by going
to a job and asking a machine to print
money for you yeah they think the only
way to make money is to go to you know a
business a corporation
and say i would like access to the money
printer right and that's just that's
that's
it's a it's a failed world view and it's
our fault for not teaching our kids
better
yeah and i think schools it is and i
think bound up within that is also a
lack of teaching of morality and i think
this is probably particularly bad as we
get into a society where
um morality is less assumed right
there's plenty of benefits to that but i
think one of the consequences is that if
we don't have a relatively fixed or
understood morality
then kids grow up in an absence of
morality as people who aren't moral
actors themselves right
they're too young that they can't
possibly understand and so for a really
long time getting back to the
you know the anthropological model you
had that was the role of the family or
the community or the culture or the
religion or whatever it is
and now we've kind of we've always
foisted that
onto a public school system that has no
idea how to do it but unfortunately more
and more
is attempting to do it and i think
that's where the real danger comes in
i'll tell you what's really amazing uh
are you christian yes yeah catholic so i
grew up catholic
and my family left the church when i was
real young and i became a disillusioned
young person
like very anti yeah anti-church and
everything and then i had an
uh an epiphany when i met someone and
and he just gave me some insight at a
couple different
moments in my life and then i became i
don't i don't necessarily want to say
agnostic i do believe in god
but i i think it's not the uh not like a
theistic
yeah it's more of an einsteinian or it's
hard to explain i have my own personal
like belief system
but i was thinking about something
really interesting because um my buddy
adam who i don't know if you met him
he's doing his own show
he has a song he wrote and we we used to
we used to jam on friday nights and he
one of his lines is that um it's time to
confess our sins
he says that one of his songs and i
thought about this and i said
the idea that a like secular urban
liberal type would understand the
concept of confessing your sins
means that he does have some
understanding of
confession yeah and that's catholic
right yeah yeah it is so if i thought it
was interesting because
if you go to another country maybe in
like east asia and and they're going to
be like what's that
yeah like i don't understand what that
is it doesn't exist in their culture
and so when you talk about a shared
morality what i think a lot of people in
this country didn't realize and i and i
learned this you know very much later on
i remember hearing from a lot of
liberals talking religion they'd say
something like
if you need religion not to like murder
and rape people then that scares me
because yeah
and i'm like but what you don't realize
is that your morals
come from the same moral foundation
right and so i
i really had an amazing moment when i
read about when i was learning about
blackstone's formulation
yeah yeah yeah you know that's rooted in
the bible yes yeah i believe sodom and
sodom and gomorrah it is if there is but
one righteous
person right and so that evolved over
time through
uh into english common law which we
brought to the united states and now we
have
the fifth amendment the right to a trial
the right to remain silent
the right the innocence until proven
guilty is
rooted quite literally it's it's so the
what i explained to people is
you might not like the bible and maybe
like the uh originalists who you know
sure yeah who view it you know as
verbatim but
what i the way i see it is we started
somewhere and maybe there's some things
in here that were
were bad but we kept the good yeah and
we carried the good with us slowly
refining and making it better and now
when you come out and say i don't need
you know a religion to tell me why i'm
moral
then i say but there are countries that
don't have the presumption of innocence
right and so the presumption of
innocence while it is separated from
from the faith we've we've kind of like
figured out that core element
right it it's it's a shared morality
from you know these similar values
so the reason i bring that up is even if
you know i think this more relates to
the the 90s
when i was growing up when you had the
democrats and a lot of secular liberal
types
who still had similar moral foundations
exactly yeah
even though the religion had been
removed from it right well now we're
entering a point where the moral
foundations
are mirror images where you have uh
black lives matter and critical race
theory saying
you know overtly racist things so uh
part of our moral foundations is that we
created the civil rights act
you know you can't discriminate against
people based on these things yeah it's
equality under the law
well now they want to erase that yeah
they say well we should be able to
discriminate to help people
and that's when our moral foundations
are now have become mirror image
so when i'm talking to my friend and i
say i refuse
to live in a world without the civil
rights act it was long fought by our
great civil rights leader we won and you
want to repeal it and their answer is
but we need to to help people
i say i don't care what you think you're
doing right the path the hell is paid
with good intentions yep exactly so
yeah i resist and i'm right there with
you and i think the the
it's it's right to say that they are in
opposition and i think one of the things
that
a lot of people particularly a lot of
people i think blm kind of forget is
the idea of um all people like i don't
say all lives matter right that's got
political context but the idea that all
the idea that all of human life
intrinsically has worth and value that
is even
and equal is a very christian concept
right this is this is saint paul's
writing this is
neither neither it's neither jew nor
greek neither slave nor free these are
christians
these were these were incredibly
unfamiliar at the time and so you're
right there's so much of this that then
gets
it gets passed down to culture it gets
passed down to common law gets passed
down to
the sort of values that we share as a
people and you're right for a really
long time we could fight about what
those values were and for a long time
obviously there's
meaningful meaningful problems in how
those values existed right particularly
before the 1960s
there were enormous enormous problems of
the way that we reflected these values
but i do think that probably from i
don't know 60s 70s 80s 90s
there was a really valuable shared
framework with which we discussed moral
issues
and we're very rapidly moving to a point
where we are throwing out the idea that
even having that
confined conversation is valuable so
here's here's kind of what i think
uh in that context where i said the
morality has shifted the base of it
i am a liberal individual uh i grew up
very briefly catholic
so i i grew up and i long have since
forgotten a lot of the stuff they taught
us in these in in catholic
school although i still remember some of
the songs it's kind of funny because we
you know
they stay with you they will always stay
they do even though as a little kid
but a lot of the moral foundations i
think that's what it is i think
i think even secular liberals don't
realize they were raised in a sort of a
judeo-christian
framework whether it's good or bad is
not the point i'm just saying we shared
a lot of these same values
i mean the ten commandments or or the
blackstone's formulation right
but now we have a new a new idea of a
new world
where we're colonizers we're evil where
white people they say you know
are evil and have all these whiteness
traits like hard work and planning for
the future and it's a really weird thing
yeah
but their moral framework is completely
inverted right so here's what i think
how is it that you and i
you know we're having a conversation you
i is it fair to say you're a catholic
conservative yeah yeah i'm like
uh uh i don't know if it's fair to say
i'm like secular i don't know what i am
but i'm not a non-theistic liberal type
yeah we agree on so much right and it's
because of a a rooted moral foundation i
think yeah exactly and again you can
quibble on
so many of the details and i think that
one of the one of the big important
things here is
what we're seeing in the streets in
places like portland those aren't
quibbles
those aren't those aren't splitting
hairs about about a 25
effective tax rate versus 27 percent
right it is a bunch of people who
fundamentally do not believe
in the rules that have governed our
entire system since like i don't know
we became an agricultural civilization
but it's beyond that it's it's like uh
well yes yes it's also in the
uh in the nitty-gritty of our current
society they believe they have a right
to use violence against you
we typically you know like for the
longest time most americans were not in
agreement
and i love it when people bring up the
weather underground they're like yeah
but you know if you want to talk about
how bad things are the weather
underground and i was like i could be
wrong
but didn't they do shock and awe
campaigns in the middle of the night
when no one was around because they
didn't want to hurt people yeah and they
ended up killing someone i think because
they were they were like they didn't
know they were going to be in there yeah
exactly right it was like their intent
and what they did was wrong like no joke
absolutely but
like they were avoiding hurting people
the people today uh
in these riots they're actively hurting
people in fact they've killed people
there's there's 15 dead from the riots
and with a chas chop they literally
killed people yeah the security guards
unloaded
according to witnesses for like a minute
just round after round into a vehicle
with some teenagers in it
because i thought the teenagers were
like white supremacists but they weren't
they were just kids
so they they're literally like light
them up and and
so much of it too and i think one my
biggest i think my biggest problem
biggest qualm with all this is
they're reframing and rephrasing the way
violence works in this defining oh
totally and so if you can say
words are violence and you really
fundamentally believe
words are violence and using the wrong
pronoun is a threat against someone
the way that lots of lots of blue check
twitter activists will tell you
these things are literal violence then
it doesn't surprise me when those same
people look at rand paul getting
assaulted and said like how is that how
is that worse than
messing up someone's pronouns how is
that worse than yeah then like the the
the drinking from the kool-aid of white
supremacy or whatever lady gaga said the
other day
words are violence silence is violence
silence too right and silence is consent
okay so uh they've covered all the bases
right yeah if you say nothing you're
being violent and consenting to
whatever's happening around you
right and so that applies in all
contexts if you don't if you're not
speaking up against the riots
then you are uh effectively condoning
them
yeah and you're also being violent
against them for not supporting them
and if you say anything you're being
violent against them therefore no matter
what you do
we must beat you there's no winning now
and really to me what comes down to is
it's it's intellectual extortion right
you are looking at people and you are
saying you can either agree with me or
you can face
violence like it's like the sopranos if
the sopranos took over
like a twitter and academia that's what
we're seeing happen in real time
and it's amazing because there's so many
people who are kind of getting there
they've got the gun in their back or the
sword in their back they're walking the
plank and they're like
it's fine can you guys did you see what
trump tweeted about today like it's such
a big concern
and they don't see what's going on
around them and the radical truly
radical shifts that we're seeing in the
way that that are the discourse just
takes place
i wonder you know elaborating on this
moral uh
you know shared moral framework idea i
wonder if the reason why we kind of have
default liberals
you know people who just kind of vote
democrat and don't really pay attention
is because they don't really have any
kind of moral framework so they just
default to the left and they say sure
whatever then you have the far leftists
who have a radically different moral
framework where
their power is paramount and and the
health of the tribe and the survival of
the tribe is more important than
individual rights
then you have the traditional american
faction which includes liberals and
conservatives
and that is a shared moral framework on
specific
uh i i guess i guess it's fair to say
judeo christian values kind of we were
founded as a christian nation
but um it's it's it's it's become
something a bit broader than that but
there is a rooted shared moral framework
so yeah
so i wonder if the reason why what i'm
saying is there
are you know people who are just not
paying attention right who will go out
and vote for joe biden without knowing
anything about what's going on
and it could be because their moral
framework is is absent
they're just they're just i want to feed
my family i don't care anything else
yeah exactly and i think that's i think
that's a good way to look at it and i
think part of it too
is there's a lot of people who in the
absence of having a particularly
firm moral framework it's really easy to
adopt my catholic is really showing here
but
it can be really easy to adopt a worldly
moral framework
right and so if your moral framework is
basically
i don't know twitter and facebook
and whatever video you find on youtube
and the movies that you watch in the
video games you play
then that that can be super super
problematic for in a lot of different
reasons and so
i think it can be easy to adopt that
instead and that that that is destined
to fail
but that that's that that's almost that
passive sort of framework that ends up
resulting you know i've had a video
on my main channel about jordan peterson
for a long time
i've never it's like my default video
from years ago and i basically talk
about how
we're we're experiencing a crisis of
purpose
where you have a lot of far leftists who
they don't know their purposes
so they've created one yes it's
challenging the empire and white
supremacy right but then you have a lot
of other people who have no purpose so
they just sit around playing video games
all day
then they find someone like jordan
peterson who tells them here's how you
develop purpose yeah
you know find the heaviest thing you can
and then carry it and that is
you know a part of the culture war
people who have nothing to do and don't
understand but are longing
to do something because i think we all
are right like i think at the end of the
day and
you know i think peterson really struck
a chord i think with a lot of people for
exactly that reason it's
he understands that people fundamentally
and a lot of cases particularly young
men are
striving for some level of meaning in a
world that has very very little meaning
and outside of the more traditional like
i need to go be a blacksmith because i
need to keep
growing the family blacksmith building
or outside the you know the confines of
traditional faith
it can be really really hard to find
something and so if you've got this
quasi religion and leftism
it's a really really easy thing to glam
onto we've uh we've kind of won
we have abundance of food we're all
overweight yeah
so what do people do and so they just
they got to figure something out
otherwise what's the meaning of life why
are they alive
and then they just i don't know they sit
in their bedrooms bored and scared
but they found a new meeting in this in
this new dogma right because at the end
of the day what critical race theory i
think gives a lot of people a really
great excuse to do is
it gives them easy bad guys there are
monsters they can go out and slay the
monsters that are very obviously in
front of them
and i don't know maybe behind them in
line at the supermarket too it's
everywhere it's omnipresent this awful
terrible thing
that is toxic whiteness or toxic
masculinity or toxic whatever you want
to get mad about
if it's everywhere then every day of
your life can have meaning it's like
you're on a giant open-ended rpg video
game
where you're an adventurer where yeah
you're going on an adventure and there's
always going to be some monster that
crawls out of the forest that you get to
be the righteous one to destroy
and the problem is the people that they
always happen to find in the issues they
keep finding
aren't monsters right and there's no one
to tell them they're not monsters
right there's no great enemy thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you